[Musik]
seit 19 tagen besetzt müllsammlern
nikolassee einen baukran in münster der
38 jährige münsteraner hatte nur drei
flaschen wasser dabei und trinkt
inzwischen seinen orie angeblich aus
protest gegen das ordnungsamt dass ihm
zwei einkaufswagen mit gesammelten
abfall weggenommen hatte
seitdem er auf dem kran sitzt ist die
davor liegende straße gesperrt die
baustelle liegt steht an jedem tag an
dem die baustelle still steht fallen
kosten von 25.000 euro an bei aktuell 19
tagen stillstand sind das mal eben knapp
500.000 euro nicolas t ist in münster
berüchtigt nervt seit jahren nachbarn im
ortsteil kinderhaus weil er sein
grundstück zu mit bereits fünf mal
räumten die behörden das gelände und
vernichteten tonnenweise ab weiter also
er hat jetzt mittlerweile zum zweiten
mal den kram besetzt jetzt seit gut drei
wochen also montag glaube ich sonst
reform und diesmal beweist daraufhin
fall mehr sitzfleisch da oben jetzt kann
man nicht genau sagen ich glaube das war
nicht von anfang an abgesperrt so dass
er vielleicht zwischendurch immer unten
gewesen ist aber hier kommen auch immer
wieder leute vorbei die sich das
natürlich an cook mit ihm sprechen und
dass das auch so ein bisschen anstalten
ich glaube die stadt versucht hier so
ein bisschen so einen anderen kurs zu
fahren das jetzt so ein bisschen
aussitzen das erste mal war ja echt mal
mit polizei alles abgesperrt und so und
das eben daher keine plattform bieten
sich dabei das fest zu da die polizei
den mann offenbar aus
sicherheitstechnischen gründen nicht so
einfach von dem kran herunter holen kann
ist sie auf dessen vernunft angewiesen
den kran eigenständig zu verlassen doch
das könnte noch etwas dauern denn ein
ende seines kran aufenthaltes ist noch
nicht in sicht
[Musik]